[Musik]
das österreichische bundesheer ist immer
für uns da
darauf ist verlass
gegründet nach den schrecken des zweiten
weltkrieges ist unser bundesheer seit
jeher das schutzschild für unser land
[Musik]
als verlässlicher partner sind wir weit
über die grenzen europas hinaus bekannt
und aushängeschild unserer republik
[Musik]
weltweit bewundert man uns für unsere
tradition und kultur
doch der dienst beim bundesheer war nie
einfach nur eine schöne uniformen glanz
der ballsäle es war schon immer viel
viel mehr
denken wir an die russlandkrise als wir
unsere grenzen schließen mussten
oder an das unglück in galtür die
hochwasser unser bundesheer war immer
zur stelle
[Musik]
im laufe der geschichte hat sich eines
gezeigt genauso wie sich die aufgaben
unseres bundesheeres wandel so muss sich
auch das bundesheer selbst wandeln
als es im kalten krieg darum ging die
grenzen von möglichen feinden zu
schützen da hat sich unser bundesheer
mit schwerem gerät gerüstet mit flugzeug
und rader zur luftraumüberwachung hat
unser bundesheer begonnen auch den
luftraum zu schützen
all diese bedrohungen bestehen in
abgewandelter form auch heute noch und
deshalb rüsten wir laufend nach um immer
besser und immer moderner zu werden
heute stehen wir zusätzlich vor vielen
neuen herausforderungen terror pandemien
blackouts cyberangriffe oder auch
naturkatastrophen
das sind die bedrohungsszenarien unserer
zeit für die wir uns rüsten müssen die
vision für unser bundesheer ist klar
unser heer muss schnell sein
es muss schlagkräftig sein und es muss
am puls der zeit sein um immer dann für
österreich da zu sein wenn wir es
brauchen
unser heer muss unsere grenzen und
unseren luftraum weiterhin schützen
es muss bei katastrophen wie lawinen
hochwasser
und pannen ihn für uns da sein
und es muss sich an internationalen
missionen beteiligen um konflikte dort
zu lösen wo sie entstehen
aber unser bundesheer muss auch wird die
italy kämpfe bereit sein es muss cyber
angriffe auf unsere republik abwehren
können und blackouts verhindern
unser heer leistet schutz und hilfe in
der mitte der gesellschaft
[Musik]
das österreichische bundesheer immer für
uns da
[Musik]